FBI DEPUTY DIRECTOR ANDREW
McCABE.
WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT HOW THE
SEARCH UNDERFOLDED WHERE YOU ARE
IN PENNSYLVANIA?
>> WELL IT IS VERY FASCINATING
BECAUSE FIRST OF ALL, HE WAS
ARRESTED EARLY THIS MORNING IN
ALBRIGHTSVILLE PENNSYLVANIA AND
I'M IN A RURAL AREA OF
NORTHEASTERN PENNSYLVANIA.
BRIGHTSVILLE IS ABOUT EIGHT
MILES AWAY AND THAT IS,
ACCORDING TO THE PRESSER, THAT
IS WHERE HE LIVES.
AND THEY ALSO SAID THAT THIS IS
HIS HOME.
EVEN THOUGH HE'S IN WASHINGTON
GOING TO SCHOOL IN WASHINGTON,
AND WHAT WE ARE LEARNING AS
SOURCES CONFIRMING WITH CNN THAT
THE FBI OUT OF PHILADELPHIA HAD
BEEN SURVEILLING HIM RIGHT IN
THIS AREA FOR FOUR DAYS.
AND WHILE THIS WAS GOING ON
HERE, IN IDAHO THEY WERE
ACTUALLY -- THE FBI AND THE
LOCAL POLICE, IDAHO STATE
POLICE, THEY WERE GETTING
TOGETHER THE INFORMATION SO THEY
WOULD HAVE THE PROBABLE CAUSE TO
GO BEFORE A JUDGE TO GET THE
ARREST WARRANT.
AND THE SOURCE TELLS CNN THAT
THE ARREST WARRANT PROBABLE
CAUSE IS BASED ON DNA, HIS DNA
BEING AT THE SCENE AND ALSO THAT
WHITE CAR THAT WE'VE HEARD SO
MUCH ABOUT, THAT WAS SCENE
THROUGH SOME VIDEO CLOSE TO THE
APARTMENT AT THE TIME THIS WAS
HAPPENING.
THAT WAS HIS CAR.
WELL ONCE THEY GOT THAT ARREST
WARRANT, THE CRIMINAL COMPLAINT
WAS FILED AND WE HEARD FROM THE
PRESS CONFERENCE IT WAS FILED
YESTERDAY.
FOUR COUNTS OF FIRST-DEGREE
MURDER.
ALSO A BURGLARY CHARGE AND ONCE
THAT WAS FILED, THEY WENT IN
THIS MORNING AT 1:30 A.M. TO A
GATED COMMUNITY AND THEY
ARRESTED HIM AND HE IS HERE NOW
WAITING AN EXTRADITION HEARING
WHICH WILL BE ON TUESDAY.
>> STAND BY.
I WANT TO BRING IN JON MILLER.
WHAT MORE COULD YOU TELL US,
JON, ABOUT THE SUSPECT AND THIS
DRAMATIC ARREST, MORE THAN A
MONTH AFTER THESE MURDERS.
>> WELL, WOLF, THIS CAME
TOGETHER REALLY IN LAST FEW
DAYS.
ONCE THEY PUT THAT FBI
SURVEILLANCE TEAM ON HIM, IN
THIS RURAL AREA, THAT WAS THE
CLEAR SIGN THAT WE'RE DEVELOPING
THIS, WE'RE MOVING TOWARD THAT
ARREST BUT WE NEED TO KNOW WHERE
THE SUSPECT IS BECAUSE WE CAN'T
JUST KEEP DEVELOPING EVIDENCE
AND THEN GO LOOK FOR HIM AND
FIND OUT THAT HE'S IN THE WIND.
SO ONCE THEY WERE ABLE TO WHAT
THEY CALL ACQUIRE HIM, WHICH IS
WE'VE GOT EYES ON AND WE KNOW
WHERE HE IS, WE'RE DEVELOPING
HIS PATTERN OF LIFE, WHERE HE
COMES AND GOES, VERY HARD TO DO
IN A RURAL AREA WHERE ANY
STRANGE BEINGS OR CARS STAND OUT
TO NEIGHBORS RIGHT AWAY.
WHICH IS PROBABLY WHY THEY
NEEDED SO MANY PEOPLE.
BUT ONCE THEY DEVELOPED THAT
SURVEILLANCE TEAM, THAT WAS NOW
WE'VE GOT TO DOT THE I'S AND
CROSS THE T'S AND GET A JUDGE TO
SIGN OFF ON THE ARREST WARRANT
AND GET A JUDGE TO AUTHORIZE IT
IN PENNSYLVANIA.
AND THEN PENNSYLVANIA STATE
TROOPER JUSTIN LEERY EXECUTED
THAT WARRANT WITH THE FBI AND
ADDITIONAL TROOPERS AND HE'S IN
CUSTODY.
BUT AS HAS BEEN POINTED OUT BY
VERONICA, THE DNA AND THE CAR IS
WHAT GOT THEM TO PROBABLE CAUSE.
>> TWO MAJOR DEVELOPMENTS
INDEED.
ANDREW McCABE, THE AUTHORITIES
AT THAT NEWS CONFERENCE TODAY
DIDN'T GIVE ANY INFORMATION ON
ANY POSSIBLE LINKS THE SUSPECT
MAY HAVE HAD TO THESE FOUR
VICTIMS.
WHAT QUESTIONS DO YOU HAVE ABOUT
ANY LINKS AND POSSIBLE MOTIVE
FOR THAT MATTER?
>> WELL, WOLF, I MEAN THAT IS
THE CENTRAL QUESTION I'M SURE
THAT ALL OF US HAVE RIGHT NOW.
WHAT BROUGHT THIS YOUNG MAN TO
THAT HOUSE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT.
WE DON'T -- WE, OF COURSE, IT IS
NOT NECESSARY TO PROVE MOTIVE TO
CONVICT SOMEONE OF MURDER HERE
IN THIS COUNTRY.
IT IS NOT AN ELEMENT OF THE
OFFENSE.
BUT IT IS VERY HELPFUL WHEN YOU
ARE TRYING TO CONVINCE A JURY
THAT AN INDIVIDUAL HAS, YOU
KNOW, AS THE POLICE HAVE SAID IN
THIS CASE, PICKED OUT OR
TARGETED THESE VICTIMS, JURORS
WANT TO KNOW WHY, WHAT IS THE
CONNECTION BETWEEN THIS GUY AND
HIS VICTIMS.
SO THAT IS WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND.
IT IS CLEAR THAT THE OFFICIALS
IN IDAHO ARE GREATLY LIMITED BY
THEIR OWN STATE LAW AND SUPREME
COURT STATE RULES IN TERMS OF
WHAT THEY COULD SAY ABOUT THE
INVESTIGATION BEFORE HE IS
PRESENTED BEFORE A JUDGE IN
IDAHO.
SO HOPEFULLY WE'LL LEARN MORE
ABOUT THAT ONCE THEY GET HIM
BACK TO IDAHO.
BUT THAT IS CLEARLY THE KEY
QUESTION IN ALL OF OUR MINDS.
>> POLICE ARE STILL LOOKING FOR
THE MURDER WEAPON AND ASKING FOR
THE PUBLIC'S HELP WITH ANY
INFORMATION ON THE SUSPECT.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
>> WELL, I MEAN, IT MAY OR MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO FIND A MURDER
WEAPON.
YOU HAVE A 2500 MILE DISTANCE
BETWEEN WHERE THE MURDERS DURRED
AND WHERE HE WAS ARRESTED.
HE DROVE, AND ANYTHING COULD
HAPPEN.
AND THEY'LL CONTINUE TO LOOK.
THERE IS NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
BUT OUR UNDERSTANDING RIGHT NOW
IS THAT THEY HAVE DNA, THEY HAVE
SOMETHING THAT SHOWS THE CAR IN
THAT PARTICULAR AREA.
NOW THAT THEY HAVE THE CAR, I'M
CERTAIN THEY'LL LOOK FOR ANY
TRACE EVIDENCE TO SEE IF
THINKING THAT WOULD LINK THE
VICTIMS OF THE CRIME THAT BLOOD
EVIDENCE WHICH WAS NOT EASY TO
GET RID OF AND THAT HAD TO BE A
VERY BLOODY CRIME SCENE.
SO THERE IS STILL A LOT OF WORK
TO BE DONE IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE.
BUT THE WAY IT SOUNDS RIGHT NOW,
I DON'T THINK THEY NEED THE
MURDER WEAPON.
IT COULD BE GREAT TO GET IT BUT
I DON'T THINK THEY NEED IT.
I THINK THEY'VE GOT ENOUGH OF A
CASE RIGHT NOW TO MOVE FORWARD
BUT THEY'LL CONTINUE TO WORK AS
HARD AS THEY CAN.
BUT I JUST WANT TO COMMEND THE
MEN AND WOMEN THAT WORKED ON
THIS CASE.
THIS WAS NOT A EASY CASE TO
SOLVE BY ANY STRETCH OF THE
IMAGINATION.
AND THEY STAYED WITH IT AND THEY
WERE ABLE TO FIND THE PERSON
RESPONSIBLE SO MY HATS OFF TO
THEM.
THAT IS JUST NOT EASY TO DO.
PEOPLE WATCH TELEVISION AND THEY
THINK EVERYTHING GETS SOLVED
WITHIN AN HOUR WITH COMMERCIAL
BREAKS.
BUT THAT IS NOT THE REALITY OF
POLICE WORK.
SO, AGAIN, GOOD JOB.
>> AND YOU SPEAK WITH A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE IN THIS AREA.
POLICE CHIEF HERE IN WASHINGTON.
THE POLICE COMMISSIONER IN
PHILADELPHIA AS WELL.
WE NOW HAVE THE AERIALS OVER THE
HOME THE SUSPECT WAS LIVING IN
IN PENNSYLVANIA.
THEY ARE SEARCHING HIS COMPLEX
IN WASHINGTON STATE AS WELL.
WHAT WILL THEY BE ON ALERT FOR.
>> WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING FOR
PRIMARILY IS THE MURDER WEAPON.
THAT IS THE BIG PRIZE RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT DNA AT THE
SCENE, YOU'VE GOT HIS CAR AT
SCENE.
IF YOU GET THE MURDER WEAPON,
THAT COMPLETES THE TRIANGLE.
THE FACT THAT IT WASN'T FOUND AT
THE SCENE COULD SUGGEST THAT HE
HAS AN ATTACHMENT TO IT.
THAT HE WANTED TO KEEP IT.
WOULD NOT BE THE FIRST KILLER TO
KEEP SOMETHING LIKE THAT AS A
SOUVENIR.
THAT WEAPON ITSELF COULD YIELD
EVIDENCE, WHETHER IT IS TRACES
OF DNA OR BLOOD AND ALSO LOOKING
FOR CLOTHING.
CLOTHING THAT HE MIGHT HAVE WORN
THAT NIGHT, THAT COULD HAVE
OTHER EVIDENCE.
SO, YOU KNOW, YOU WANT TO SEARCH
THAT APARTMENT WHERE HE LIVED
CLOSE TO THE SCENE IN WASHINGTON
STATE.
YOU WANT TO GET A WARRANT AND
FREEZE AND SEARCH THIS HOME TO
DETERMINE WHAT DID HE BRING WITH
HIM THAT COULD BE EVIDENCE OF
THE CRIME.
OBVIOUSLY A WARRANT FOR THAT CAR
AS WELL.
SO, THEY'RE GOING TO BE LOOKING
EVERYWHERE THAT HE KNOW HE
STOPPED, SLEPT OR STAYED OR HAS
BEEN TO SEE WHAT DID HE LEAVE
BEHIND THAT COULD TRACE HIM BACK
TO THAT SCENE.
>> GOOD POINT.
ANDREW McCABE, I'M ANXIOUS TO
GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS AS
WELL.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WELL I THINK I AGREE WITH
JOHN'S POINTS THERE.
I WOULD ADD TO THAT THEY'RE
PROBABLY LOOKING FOR ANY SORT OF
EVIDENCE OF CONNECTION BETWEEN
THIS SUSPECT AND THE VICTIMS AND
THAT COULD COME IN THE FORM OF
INTERNET SEARCH LOGS ON HIS
COMPUTER, IT COULD COME FROM A
CONNECTION THAT HE MIGHT HAVE
HAD WITH THE VICTIMS, VIA THE
INTERNET OR TELEPHONE OR TEXT
MESSAGES OR THOSE SORT OF
THINGS.
SO GRABBING HIS ELECTRONICS
DEVICES DURING THE COURSE OF ALL
OF THE PHYSICAL SEARCH IS VERY
IMPORTANT AND EXPLOITING THE
INFORMATION ON THERE IS VERY
IMPORTANT AND IT ALSO GOES TO
BUILDING THE TIMELINE.
YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO PUT HIM
DOWN IN A PLACE AT A LOCATION
CONDUCTING AN ACTIVITY CERTAINLY
EVERY DAY FOLLOWING THE HOMICIDE
AND ALSO AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE